KNIGHT: Welcome to the Active
Inference Institute.
This is a participatory
online laboratory.
Today is Tuesday, September 13th,
and we are here with MathStream #004.1
with David Spivak
and we are welcome to take any questions
in the YouTube chat.
So if you have any questions,
please write from there
and we will have time to
ask our presenter
during the course of this discussion.
KNIGHT: David is here to talk to us today
about dynamic interfaces
and arrangements
and algebraic
frameworks for interacting systems.
Please take it away.
SPIVAK: Okay. Yeah.
Thanks a lot for having me.
So I am going to talk for around
40 minutes,
but for maybe almost an hour,
I don't know.
But feel free to interrupt
with whatever.
And I wanted to say at the outset
that I'm not really talking much
about active inference itself here.
I'm mainly saying
like another perspective
on interacting systems or systems
that might learn or something like that.
SPIVAK: And I'm
more like waiting for the discussion
time to kind of find these links.
So yeah. Okay.
So I want to talk about
dynamic interfaces and arrangements
and what that means
and this applied category theory
point of view on things.
So, so why am I here?
I'm here to seek
a valuable exchange of ideas
because active inference offers
the first time I heard about it.
SPIVAK: It's compelling,
and most people
apparently find it unusual,
but for some reason
it instantly meshed
with my own intuition about things
that I've gotten from
applied category theory.
And so I think there's a lot
we can learn from each other.
So applied category
theory emphasizes structure
rather than quantitative analysis.
So most of math and science
today reduce all of our experience
to plays of quantity.
SPIVAK: So you have graphs and you have numbers
and you measure things in numbers
and you have probabilities
and those are numbers.
And so everything is just a number
but experience.
What's happening now?
I mean, what number would you put on?
You know, the sound of my voice or the
or what numbers?
You could put numbers on this slide,
but would they tell you
what the slide was about?
SPIVAK: And so what category theory emphasizes?
It's still math,
but it emphasizes structure.
It emphasizes relations between things
like the relationship
between what's on this slide
and other things on the slide
or what's on the rest of the talk,
the relationships
between that and meta relationship
between that and you,
and the kind of coherence
between all that.
Like, why are we really here?
SPIVAK: What is it? How does it cohere?
How does it come together?
So Applied Category
Theory aims to bring that math
to relational disciplines
outside of math.
So I want to tell you about applied
category theory
specifically in reference to interfaces,
because I'm going to say
that we interact through our interfaces.
When you hear the word interface,
you might think markup, blanket.
SPIVAK: I don't know enough
to be sure that
that's exactly what I mean.
So that's kind of where this is fitting
in, maybe into an active
inference framing,
but I'd rather
you just think about interfaces.
So I'm
asking you this
talk what sort of algebra
could support us in thinking about
interaction and stuff like that?
I think of
mathematical fields
as accounting systems, so I like that
the word count is in there
and I like how kind of humble it is.
SPIVAK: It's like an accounting system here.
So if you want to
if you have arithmetic,
that's a mathematical field
and it accounts
for the flow of quantities
like in finance.
So if you want your accountant
to help
you say why you did what you did
or what you did
and how the quantities flowed,
you would write something in
an arithmetic account,
you write an arithmetic account of it,
and then someone could point that
and say, What's this, $12.83?
SPIVAK: And you could explain.
So there is numbers
and you can account for stuff.
What if you
wanted to account
for the teleportation protocol
of quantum mechanics
or something like that?
So Hilbert Spaces is a
is a branch of math,
and it helps
you make accounts
for the sorts of things
that people do
in quantum computing
or quantum mechanics or generally.
Probability distributions
is a mathematical field,
but it helps to account for likelihoods.
Why somebody winning in poker?
Somebody not
if you want to give that account
and you want to be careful about it,
you do use probability distributions.
So but what is it? A counter phenomena?
Like we're already kind of talking
and you know,
somebody might give an account
of their finances or something
and just written in English,
but you can't really be that careful
with that. You can't track it.
You can't be sure
you know what they're saying,
that you can point at something.
So the language,
the accounting system
has to articulate
the relevant type
differences and provide operations
that correspond with their interactions.
And that's really a dumb statement.
I didn't mean to
I'm trying to keep things concise,
but what do I mean?
SPIVAK: They're in accounting for dollars
and like financial stuff,
there is dollars
and there's numbers of things
and you can add and subtract dollars
like this was $5 and he paid four.
So there's $1 left.
So you can subtract them or add them,
but you can't multiply $2 figures.
It doesn't mean anything to multiply $5
times $8,
but you can multiply $5
by eight things like.
SPIVAK: So I sold eight things of $5 each.
So the operations
that you're allowed to do
there are different type difference.
There's the number of widgets
and then there's
the price of the widgets.
And that's a difference in type.
And the operations make sense with
plus you're allowed to add dollars
and allowed to add numbers of widgets,
but you're not allowed to multiply
numbers of dollars
by numbers of dollars.
SPIVAK: So that's kind of what I mean here.
An accounting system needs to tell you,
hey, that's not a dollar.
It means
what would it even mean
to multiply $5 by $8?
Is it in dollars
squared now or something anyway?
So that's the sort of thing
that the accounting system does.
It gives you
a way of knowing
what you're allowed to do,
what the type differences are,
and what you can operate,
how you operate on them.
SPIVAK: So if every mathematical field
is an accounting system,
the category theory
is an accounting system.
So what is it accounting system for?
It's an accounting system
for the fact that we see in the world
coherent structures,
we see in the world, flows of things
we see in the world,
quantum mechanics
we see in the world, likelihoods
and we see in the world
coherent structures.
SPIVAK: So if we want to account for them,
we need some language.
And the one that's been
invented is category theory.
And so
it makes analogies
which are similarities of structure
with different content.
I've got one thing
and another thing is to be is to deep.
That similarity
is made into a formal object
and category
theory's been useful in math or computer
science, physics
or material science linguistics.
SPIVAK: And moreover,
one thing I didn't see on a slide
is that category theory helps
you invent new mathematical fields.
They might not be big ones
that are studied by a million people.
You might just have a micro custom built
accounting system
written in category theory.
So you make a new system of structure.
And what I'm interested in is
what sort of system,
accounting system,
what could we use
to account for dynamic interaction,
like things interacting?
SPIVAK: So the driving question,
I really prefer to have a
question that I can always be asking
instead of one that I need
very specific lab to do.
So I want to know what we have
right here.
I want to account
for this incredible world
that we have, because on earth
we have all these amazing forms of life
from cells to humans.
SPIVAK: How did that come about?
And we have the built world
where we have transportation systems
and things like that
and we have computers.
It's an amazing built world.
We have language, the ability
to systematically present
knowledge like a slideshow
or a history book or whatever.
We have morality with rules of thumb
for living a good life.
How did that come about?
SPIVAK: I think in each of these cases,
they evolved through the push and pull
and struggle of living.
So language is refined by continually
using language
and the way we present knowledge
or the built world,
the way we architect things,
is continually evolving.
And even morality.
Like you have a bunch of societies
that have to live together
and they evolve a way to do that.
SPIVAK: So I want to see see all that.
I want to account for that.
So what are these systems and
how do they develop
and how do we talk about them
all at once?
What language
is appropriate
for giving accounts
of this happening in action?
And can we use that language
to engineer new systems?
And then something we were talking about
just before we started
the talk
today is like what constitute health
or wisdom?
SPIVAK: What gives the system
a sense of direction,
and how come it keeps
finding good senses of direction
in the sense that evolution,
somehow
our civilization
is offering more today than it did
in the past.
So the only part of this
I'm going to discuss
is the potential accounting system
that I'm offering here
or like the beginning of it.
SPIVAK: So in other words, I don't know how
all this stuff happened.
I just
I don't want to be the one
to figure out
how all this stuff happened because it's
obviously it's more than even
then, you
know, any group of people
could really finish
or even
and I don't
even have the capacity to really start,
but I think there are many people who do
and already are doing that.
SPIVAK: And what I'm trying to offer is a way
we could put that
into some sort of accounting system.
Okay.
So this this thing that we're doing
now is the subject of a talk.
It's dynamic interaction,
morphology, the way that things form
like us institute
formed or a person forms
and behavior.
All that stuff is about little systems
that interact.
SPIVAK: And this interaction
structure itself changes through time.
And I'll explain a mathematical language
for working with that sort of thing.
But on some level,
much of this talk
will be a case of its own subject matter
in the sense that
I'm interested in the development
of life's order,
like what is how does this develop?
But in the science system,
this takes place between the
interaction between fields.
SPIVAK: So right now
you guys know much more
about active inference
and I know more about category theory.
And so we're participating
in this science system
where we're interacting
and we're having dynamic interaction,
because after this,
the part where I'm just talking,
I'm still looking at Bleu as she's
she's looking at me
and I'm seeing her nod
and that that helps me decide
what to say next and whether we're where
how this communication is working.
SPIVAK: So we're experiencing the development,
the ability for systems
interacting to shape,
shape that interaction and become
like sense, make it together
in real time here.
So
the concepts
discussed in this talk
should describe the talk itself
as an interaction.
So let me just pause for a feedback
and just kind of get someone else's
voice into the space if you're willing.
SPIVAK: Do you see like
kind of what I'm saying
that the math I'm doing,
I'm talking about here
should be capable.
I'm not going to give the description
because I'd would be like
filling out the spreadsheet
with all the facts.
But it's more like that.
The math
could offer the sort of spreadsheet
you would need to talk about
this sort of thing.
KNIGHT: So definitely like math
related to
interaction is really
what activity
is all about and fundamentally describes
sense of perception and action.
Daniel joined us for a minute.
Do you have any extra comments?
I have a feeling of something
to say here.
No.
FRIEDMAN: I would just ask, what can math describe
and where do our science
and other things that are not math
also play roles?
How do those interact?
SPIVAK: Great.
Yeah, cool.
So
I'm suggesting that math gives you
the accounting system
and that science fills it in.
But let me.
Yeah, yeah.
So I think I'm going to go into that
a little more.
But so there's
this self-reflective character
where I'm saying that
you guys
just actually participated
in an interaction with me
and like
gave a kind of sense of direction
for this talk a little bit, or at least
one thing
we want to discuss, which is what's
what's the role of math and science.
SPIVAK: And so we're kind of created co-creating
this sense,
making work that we're doing here
through our interaction.
And so that's kind of what I'm saying,
is that there's
this self-reflective thing
that the talk itself,
if you want to,
you can always dove
into this itself as a case.
So that's kind of hanging around.
But I'm not going to push
really into that.
SPIVAK: The fact
SPIVAK: that we're building
something together here too much more,
but it's here.
So
I want to talk about how theory
compresses and information,
and then there's elaboration
and there's feedback from experiment.
So I think that the compression
and elaboration
play a big role in the story.
We compress our past
into a form
that we elaborate in the present,
so we're constantly forming memories
that are not as big
as the thing that they're memory up,
but they're compressions that we can
SPIVAK: elaborate on. The present
DNA, for example, compresses,
record of who died
and who thrived in some sense
into language or for nucleotides
and theory,
any theory of the compression
of past experience.
So the free energy principle is
someone has compressed ideas about what
they've seen over and over
and over again into a very small form.
And then
whether you're talking
about DNA or memories
or the free energy principle,
these are elaborated in the present.
SPIVAK: So as I speak, this theory
about compression or whatever,
not very original, but it's here
that is an elaboration
of something
that compressed
into these slides in the past
where DNA is
somehow read by messenger RNA.
And I don't know, there's
a ribosome involved
and stuff and it's elaborated.
Those genes are producing proteins
and those proteins are elaborated to
the elaboration of that compressed code,
and they then
create a living form of the thing.
SPIVAK: So that seems really important.
And then similarly experiment in theory.
If theory is like compression
and experiments
like elaboration,
these exist
both in biological
and mathematical fields.
So almost everyone knows
everyone who knows a biology is know
that there experiments involved.
And maybe you wouldn't think
that math has experimentation,
and I think that it does.
But it's the attempt
to articulate and compute things
that tell you that's
how you are elaborated.
SPIVAK: You talk about things and you compute
and we value formalism
if it makes expression
and computation easy.
So that's the experiment.
Like how good is this thing?
Well, does
it make it easy to say what I want
and does it make it easy to compute?
So with Roman numerals here, like
I don't think this is very good
at expressing,
but I know it's really bad in computing.
SPIVAK: So if you want to multiply this
Roman numeral by this Roman numeral,
you're just kind of screwed.
There is no procedure.
You can go through.
The only procedure I know
is to translate them
into Hindi, Arabic numerals
14 and six, for example,
and then use what
these are built for,
which is using the distributive law.
So 14 is ten plus four and ten times
six is easy and four times six is easy.
SPIVAK: So you get 84
and so you translate it back into six.
But where that came from
or why there are three axes
you'll never figure out it's just 84.
So the Hindi Arabic numerals,
I'm saying, are empirically better.
Like they just win games, right?
Like Fibonacci
not only came up with the one one,
two, three, five eight sequence,
but probably more importantly,
it was the one who brought the Hindi
SPIVAK: Arabic numerals.
SPIVAK: So the Hindus
apparently invented them in.
The Arabs saved them for a long time,
and then Fibonacci found them,
brought them to to the West
and they're just better.
They just weren't.
They just won out.
And that's the way that
experiment exists in math.
How easy it is to use.
And that's the sort of value
claim I'm
making about what I'm discussing today,
that it's it's a single
accounting system.
SPIVAK: You're not constantly changing what
the notation means or
changing
how you're thinking about things.
It's all one system,
and it just works
really well with itself.
So the plan for the talk is that
it will be in for four parts.
I'll give you a presently
available case.
The thing I'm trying to model,
I'll give a whirlwind
tour of what
the math actually looks like.
SPIVAK: I'll talk about some existing
applications and open questions,
and then I'll conclude with a summary.
Okay,
so the current dynamic arrangement,
so this Zoom call
that we're having right now
and maybe with the YouTube livestream
and the people on the chat
and Cetera is a dynamic arrangement.
So how do we think about it?
I want to break it into three structures
interfaces, dynamics and interaction.
SPIVAK: So I'm going to have like
I think overall six keywords
and these are three of them and I'm
sorry there's so many, but they
all are different.
So
each one of us has an interface.
So it's what I can express and take it.
I'm expressing through the changes
of my vocal chords
and the movement of my hands.
And I'm taking in information
through the sensations
in my body and my eyes and my ears.
SPIVAK: And then each one of us has dynamics.
So I have some internal state
that you can't see exactly,
but I'm in it
in some mood and I'm expecting to read
and all that sort of stuff.
And then that's updated
by what I see
you guys doing or
what I'm reading on the screen.
And then between us
there's interaction,
which is how my output, my expression
affects you,
how your expression affects me.
SPIVAK: So those are what I think is going on.
A lot of what's going on
in this dynamic arrangement between us,
it's it's
really useful
to draw boundaries around things.
So you modularized by nesting
reference frames
we have little reference frames.
I mean by that
I don't necessarily mean the thing
they mean in relativity theory,
although I think that would be a case.
SPIVAK: A reference
SPIVAK: frame is just a
a box you put around things and you say,
I can refer to this as Alice
and this is Bob and stuff like that.
I want a frame
where I get to have a notation
or a way to refer to things,
and we have littler systems
interacting within bigger systems
all the time.
We could say that atom, with its
electron
orbitals or whatever is some kind of
reference frame or so.
SPIVAK: But atoms
and molecules
we could think of the molecules
of reference frame for all of its atoms.
You can point to them and refer to them.
Organizations and societies.
We modularized
and we say, that's the thing,
that's the thing, that's the thing.
And we are putting things together
and that's useful in evolution.
So for example,
according to Herbert Simon,
like that's how evolution is so fast
is because it
modularized is our liver and our stomach
and let them evolve independently
but also
or various systems,
circulatory or nervous system, etc..
SPIVAK: But also
it's useful in the way
we think humans think about things.
I want to emphasize again
that the math here
will not be numerical,
it will be structural.
So as we move into the math,
you'll see how it manages
these reference frames.
And so like geometry is about shapes.
Geometry doesn't have much number in it,
but there are numbers a little bit.
SPIVAK: There is like how big the angle is
and how big the sides are,
but it's really about the shapes
and the congruent spins
and stuff like that.
And similarly you can put it,
you can put numbers
into category theory,
it accepts that,
but it's really about the structure
of why you're using those numbers
and which numbers can
be added to other numbers or what
the rules are about the numbers.
SPIVAK: And really you don't need numbers
at all.
The relationships that are happening
here, for example, are not numerical.
But before we get there,
let's make sure we understand
our principal subject, because
we'd like this math to
be able to describe things
we work with, like cells or tadpoles
or us or institutes or whatever.
And I'll define what I mean
by interface as a mathematical object.
SPIVAK: But I want to ground this
talk in something
we can all think about together.
And since we don't have cells
or tadpoles here, we're the subject.
So this, this, this zoom call, let's say
with a library and all
that is the subject.
How do we think about ourselves?
Well, each
one of us can do
certain things
and receive certain things. Okay.
So I can move and listen.
We each outwardly express
and take in what we what we do there
with what I'm calling our interfaces.
I said before,
and I'm going to call these things,
the blue will always
be the things we can do.
So it's like the positions of my body
and the green will be what I can take
in, kind of like what
force the forces that act on me or
the sensorium. I have
that act on me.
So any expression,
whether it's a sound or attitude,
is a kind of position.
It's a position
I'm taking in kind of popular parlance
or whatever.
Someone's expressing themselves
or taking a position.
But you could also imagine
the position of my vocal cords
moving around
and that that movement of position
is an expression
that comes out of sound.
SPIVAK: Your inner states are reflected
outwardly as these positions.
It's happening
maybe faster than you can recognize
in the case of vocal cords.
But it's still an expression
using the blue positions,
the outward expression,
and then the world impinges on you
or in me, and it directs me
and it moves me by forces.
So when I see,
you know,
there could be literal forces on me
or you could just say,
Hey, would you mind passing the salt?
SPIVAK: And that impinges on me.
It directs me to pass the salt
that moves me.
Maybe I don't do it,
but at least it changes
my internal state to being
being stubborn or
something or to being helpful.
So what your body can receive
in a moment.
This is a kind of weird one.
I'm not going to emphasize it
that much, especially later.
SPIVAK: But it's true.
I think that what your body can receive
in a moment depends on its position.
So when your eyes are open,
that type of thing
you can get in through
your eyes is bigger
than when your eyes are closed
so more can act on you.
If I close my eyes,
I just don't know what you're
what you're doing.
SPIVAK: And when your car goes through a tunnel,
the GPS stops receiving.
And when you unplug your monitor
from your computer, it's no longer
or your keyboard
is no longer receiving things.
So the position can affect
what it can receive.
The monitor is no longer
receiving from the computer
if you disconnect.
SPIVAK: So the story so far is that you output
blue positions and you value E
and you input forces.
And so the force or sensation
or input that you receive changes
your internal state.
And then your state is reflected
outwardly as a new position.
I move my eyes
or my head or my voice box
and a new sensor,
and then if I close my eyes, open
my eyes, I have this.
SPIVAK: Whatever happens,
it may be the same
space of sensations or different,
but I see new sensations
and those change my internal state, etc.
etc.
So this is repeat
loops repeatedly,
either discretely if you want to model
it that way or continuously.
But then
where do these forces inputs come from?
They come from this interaction.
So the way that we're arranged
here, we're calling in an arrangement
and that's going to be another key word.
SPIVAK: Zoom arranges it.
So that my outputs get to you as inputs
so you can hear me.
And if you,
as you receive
what I say, your body shifts
and that's your output.
And that comes to me.
So the way this works
is based on the arrangement
that we're calling Zoom.
And so now we have another color orange
and the program arranges
it so we can input each other's outputs
and our interaction with the program
and change the arrangement itself.
SPIVAK: So if Daniel wanted to,
he could spotlight me or mute me
or change how the information is passed.
And so
the very things that you're doing,
the outputs that Daniel is doing or me,
I could ask him to do that
or I could be myself.
The part of our outputs
have the ability
to change the arrangement between us.
SPIVAK: We can walk away or whatever.
You don't have to actually hear me.
I don't know why you're smiling,
but I'm imagining
you doing some practical joke.
Okay, so I'm going to move into the
math now.
Yeah.
Okay.
So this algebraic theory of interfaces
and arrangements,
there's a bunch of words
we're going to use,
and here are the six,
I think one, two, three,
four or 507 interfaces
switching positions,
forces, states,
arrangements, enclosures, nothing.
SPIVAK: I don't think I've said
all of them so far,
but they shouldn't be too bad
at this point.
So we each have an interface.
It's what we can.
It's that through which we interact,
our interfaces
allows ourselves
to express ourselves
outward to our position.
And given a position,
our interface
allows us to receive
certain forces or sensations.
Our state is changed by the
by the received force,
and then our state
is expressed as a position.
SPIVAK: So we're state changes
based on what we see,
and then we express it
and then multiple
interfaces interact together
via their current arrangement.
How we're arranged together
doesn't have to be spatial arrangement.
We are the three of us
here on the zoom call are arranged.
I guess, in space.
But really more importantly in terms
of how Zoom wants to arrange us
and we also interact with our enclosure,
which is the thing
outside is another interface.
SPIVAK: And these arrangements can be nested
hierarchically.
So here's a picture
and it's kind of schematic.
It's not supposed to be
what we really are,
but every box here is an interface.
So I have one, two, three, four, five.
But I also have
why one is an interface,
why two is an interface, and this
is an interface.
And the way
we want to draw it is that
the interfaces
each interface has on the right,
I'm going to draw the positions,
SPIVAK: the outputs.
SPIVAK: So this thing is pushing out stuff
to the right
and on the left
it's inputting forces or directions.
So maybe this is me here
and I'm seeing through my eyes
and I'm outputting
some visual signal
and I'm putting some auditory signal,
and then somebody else is receiving
that auditory signal
and seeing some other thing,
and then other person
is saying something and doing something.
SPIVAK: Okay.
SPIVAK: So each box will have the positions.
It can be on the left,
on the right, sorry.
And the inputs or sensations
or forces on the left.
And my outputs
become things
that force you
or direct you or push you or
our input to you
if we're connected like this.
So inside of each box you could imagine
there's a state
and it's changing based on
what's coming in
from the left hand wires.
SPIVAK: So inside of each box, the state
and it's it's being affected by
what's left and is pushing out
data on the right
and then the multiple interfaces
are interacting together
in this arrangement.
So why one is supposed to be
the outer box
here, this middle sized red box
is why one, the arrangement
is this formation of wires here.
SPIVAK: This one thing is the enclosure.
It is enclosing
these three things
like public
institute encloses
some workers inside of it, or I enclose
some organs inside of me
or something like that.
And then these arrangements
finally can be nested hierarchically.
So there is me and there's you,
and then we're communicating.
But inside of us is more stuff.
And then we're forming this to call.
SPIVAK: Okay.
SPIVAK: I hope
SPIVAK: all that terminology is making sense
and feels natural.
The thing I
didn't say
here and it's very hard to draw
is that the arrangements can
change through time
based on what flows within them.
So if I say, Hey, please
mute me or something like that,
it might
change the arrangement
so that you're no longer receiving
from me.
SPIVAK: So the arrangement can change your time
based on what flows
at the end of this call.
When we say goodbye,
it will change the arrangement.
Okay,
so now we're really moving into mass.
So as we said,
the interface consists of two things
a set of positions.
Maybe I can be in three positions
A, B or C
or maybe I have 44 real numbers
worth of positions.
SPIVAK: I'm just outputting this gigantic
44 dimensional vector
constantly or something.
But whatever you
the point is to
make an accounting system
so you can model what you think
are being what the positions are.
Maybe you can
you can decide for yourself
which set of positions are being
being of type A could have
what set a position
as being a type B could have.
SPIVAK: So secondly, for every position,
there's a set of forces F,
F, bracket orbit
or inputs
you could call this consortium.
It's what can arrive
when you're in that position.
If you're a protein and you're folded
up, maybe you just can't receive
certain things on your interior.
You don't receive charge.
But when you're unfolded, your
receiving charge
or if you're a hedgehog,
as Tony Smyth says, when you're folded
up, you can't receive stuff
on your belly or something.
SPIVAK: Okay, so, so we'll encode
this as a polynomial
in a single variable y
y y because it stands for unit
in category theory
and because it doesn't,
I don't know, somehow it kind of
makes you realize
this isn't your standard
polynomial, it's not an x.
I don't know.
I just use y.
It's traditional for me at this point
and this is going to be a polynomial
with non-negative coefficients.
SPIVAK: When you think of polynomials,
you might think about numbers
in like
x squared of five
is 25 and stuff like that.
But I'm not going to be
plugging in numbers
into these polynomials.
They're really just ways of housing,
the data structure
or like what
we're going to want to work with.
So I know it's strange,
but it works really well and it's formal
and I don't mean to freak out
when you see the sum sign,
because even though I'm showing you
the map and not intending for you
to like
completely follow it or need it,
it's an accounting system,
but like Fibonacci coming to the
West, like you might not
SPIVAK: be able to use it right
away, but
but if you're interested, you'll,
you could work.
So an interface might be
this would be the whole interface
if you set up positions P
And this dummy variable
Y that's always just going to be there
because it kind of holds
the place for this exponent
and the exponent in the position
ie is the set of forces
you can get in position.
SPIVAK: II
So now we've made math
for this interface thing
which has positions
and for every position, a set of forces
that can depend on the position,
whether your eyes are closed
or open, etc.
So imagine the interface was the sum
y y cubed like you buy cubed 62 times
y to the zero zero.
You add all those up
that would have one position.
SPIVAK: It had five inputs.
So this sensorium,
when the person's in this position
would be five possible distinctions
it could make,
whereas in these 62 positions
they could run around the 62 and b
you would watch them running around here
and every time you would
know they're receiving three
possible
distinctions as
inputs, whereas
when they're over here,
they're receiving five.
SPIVAK: When they're over here,
they're receiving the zero
they they can't receive ever
they can't receive.
Here's another polynomial
r cubed y to the right of the million.
If it satisfies this thing,
these don't have to be set.
It's finite sets.
So in this thing,
it's positions,
it runs around are three.
So now it's
running around
not only on the surface of the earth,
but it's just running around
wherever it wants to
in some kind of fixed
coordinates system of the world,
of the universe.
SPIVAK: And at any point, no matter where it is,
it's always receiving exactly a million
inputs.
So maybe it's receiving a thousand
by thousand image.
It's got some.
So that is what is receiving.
But you just make your own.
It's an accounting system
for you
to make your own thing,
your own interface,
and you can make as many as you want.
SPIVAK: So why why do all this craziness
with polynomials?
Because what's amazing to me
is that the polynomial operations
mean things in terms of interfaces.
We can add polynomials.
You know how to do that.
You can multiply polynomials.
You might remember
you do some kind of people call it foil.
You just kind of multiply polynomials.
You can compose two polynomials
like P of Q,
but then there's some operations
you probably haven't
heard of,
like tensor and or an internal hum.
SPIVAK: And these are just
these are
what are called
manual structures
on and a manual closure
on a category of polynomials.
And I'm not telling you what that means.
If you do a category theory,
you can look at it.
You know already what it means.
But
but they all mean something to us in
terms of what you can do to interfaces.
SPIVAK: I'm just repeating this interface here.
So if I had one of these called P
and you had one of these called Q,
you could add them,
you could multiply them, you
could compose them, etc.
So suppose P and
you are
polynomials representing
two different interfaces.
Then what?
P plus Q Well, it's another,
it's another polynomial.
So it again represents an interface
and it would be the sort of,
it would be
the interface
that can output
a position of P or if you
and its consortium in a given position
is whichever
if it's a position of P,
it would be the consortium of that thing
or the forces there.
If it's a position of
Q would be the sensorimotor forces
that you can get there.
So if he was this interface,
this kind of thing, that output,
these sorts of positions
and input, these sorts of forces and.
Q Is this one then? P plus?
Q Is what nine Y to the fifth
plus two Y to the fourth plus y cubed?
SPIVAK: And that would be like a machine
that can be either
in one of these three states
or one, these six states,
sorry, positions.
And when they are,
they'd be input
inputting five possible distinctions
or one of these two
inputting for possible
distinction, etc..
So
that's what P plus Q represents.
It's something
making a new interface,
but P times Q represents
making a new interface
in a different way.
SPIVAK: Something with this interface
would output.
Both of
you have to like to remember
how you multiply polynomials
for basically the sum ends
of the product. Polynomial.
A sum
end of this thing is a sum
end of P and a sum end up Q.
So the positions of this thing
would be a pair consisting
of position of P and a position of Q,
but an input there or a sensation
or distinction you can make.
SPIVAK: There would be one of either P or a Q
because like just
if you remember, like what
a p was five
Y to the force
output, five different things
and inputs for no matter what.
And key was six y cubed
outputting six
and inputting three
that when you multiply them
you would output 30.
I'm just multiplying
straight across here
30 Y to the seventh
so you output both a position MP
and a position and Q a position
in a five by six grid.
SPIVAK: Here are.
And then you'd input one of seven things
either something to P or something to Q.
That's just what times does.
You could say, Well,
I want to input to both of them.
I don't want to input to
just one or the other.
And then you're using
a different operation called Tensor.
So P ten tensor
Q takes these two things and multiplies
both positions
and the directions and the sensoria
and lets you output both and input both
all the time.
SPIVAK: So this operation does that
times operation does.
When I said
plus operation
does that composition,
is it interesting?
One, when you compose polynomials,
what it would do is an output
would be something that output a P
and then also a strategy
for no matter what the P input was,
an output, a q
it doesn't,
it doesn't have to wait for you
to tell it what the input to P was.
SPIVAK: It'll just
give you the strategy
for automatically output
an accusing once you know an input.
So it runs P then Q in series and then.
Yeah.
And so
this thing kind of outputs a protocol.
I think I'm going to see
that on the next slide
a little better so
or pretty soon
the or operation runs either
P or Q or both in parallel.
SPIVAK: And then this bracketing operation
runs arrangements for wiring.
If you
if you remember what that means, like
I'll get into this a little more,
but this one is going to output
arrangements of P and Q
and input what flows on the wires.
So that's going to be an interesting
one for us later.
And I'm really saying
is that all these different operations
take interfaces
and make new interfaces out of them,
and that allows you to kind of build
things up modular.
SPIVAK: We're also going to be able to
we can also formalize
the notion of arrangement.
So we thought about ourselves
in the Zoom call as an arrangement
because Zoom lets
my outputs
be your inputs and vice versa.
But you can also think about cells
and organs and or cells or cell organ
arranged in a cell or cells in a tissue.
SPIVAK: The arrangement is
just how the information passes
between those interfaces.
I'm not so concerned
about the spatial arrangement
except as it allows information to pass
between the interfaces.
So here's a picture again
and the or
interesting of the arrangement.
So two things about this picture.
You can see that
the arrangement is how information
passes between interfaces.
You can kind of see it visually, but
two things about
this will be generalized.
SPIVAK: First, the information sharing can be
much messier.
You don't,
you don't except in the circuit.
You don't just have a perfect wires.
The inputs here might be affected
by all sorts of stuff.
And second,
the information sharing can change,
like the interfaces can change shape.
I might close my eyes,
but also the thing I say to
you might change your inner interaction.
SPIVAK: So that's contained in this notion of
an arrangement.
So formally, if you do know
category theory,
then you've probably heard
of categories,
sphincters and natural transformations.
And polynomials
are in fact folders
from set to set and arrangement.
It looks like this picture,
but all I mean by
it is a natural transformation
of polynomials.
So every one of these pictures
can be translated
into a natural transformation
of polynomial functions.
SPIVAK: And what this picture would be is
you take the little arrangement,
little interfaces, p one,
P2P three, four, five,
you would tensor them together
and then the arrangement itself
would be a natural transformation
from P1 10 to 2055 to.
Q The outer outer interface here
now what's happening?
So brief interlude for matter stuff.
I just told you
that an arrangement
is not for transformation
of polynomial functions
and all that category theory
and I'm not expecting you to know
category theory.
SPIVAK: I'm not expecting the audience
till category three.
So what's up with why?
Why would I even tell you that stuff?
I'm just trying to show you
what the math looks like.
Let any technical person in the audience
who does know category theory
see that I'm
what I'm talking about
and kind of know
where to look for what's next.
SPIVAK: But for everyone else or everyone.
I just want to show
what the math looks like
and what it's about,
because so much of math is quantitative,
or maybe it's about shapes or something,
but this math is really different.
So I want you to see it
because I want you to ask like,
what is it?
How is this math and what is it for?
SPIVAK: And the point is, it's about interfaces.
It's about time
you manipulate them,
how you arrange them,
how you guess them.
And interfaces have outputs and inputs
and they're captured.
That can depend on the outputs.
And that sort of structure
is kind of hard to talk about cleanly,
but it's really well
captured with polynomials
not considered as functions,
but it's like ways of holding structure.
SPIVAK: And then you can do these operations
to the polynomials
and they
they let you make
new interfaces from old
and we'll be talking about arrangements
and dynamics next.
But again,
they'll just be in this category
of polynomial functions
that it's all kind
of the same story again and again.
We don't have to
change our accounting system
to move
between interfaces, arrangements,
nesting dynamics, etc..
SPIVAK: Okay, so dynamics,
let's look at this arrangement again.
What is every API,
all these PS had a dynamical system
running it.
Well then what
I'm saying here is that Q
therefore would too.
So a dynamical system is a thing
with states that evolve through time.
My current emotional state
or the state of life
where I think
I am going to talk or whatever
is my current state.
SPIVAK: And then I look at you guys
and I see what you're looking like
or I'll read the slide
and then it changes and then I
output something.
So that's what a dynamical system is.
And then it can be formalized
as a system about ease or,
or a discrete dynamical system.
Or you can just think of it
as a high level idea.
SPIVAK: And I've said this so many times now,
but I'll say over time
you're in a state
that shows up as your position,
in other words, your output,
and then any possible input
you get would change your state.
And right.
So the math could be discrete
or continuous. It both works.
This formula set up.
So mathematically a dynamical system
one P is a natural transformation
swi to the s to p
where s is a set of states.
SPIVAK: Again, why am I telling you this?
Because all the math looks the same.
Whether you're talking
about arrangements
as natural transformation
between polynomial countries,
or you're talking about
dynamical
systems themselves
and happening these interfaces,
they're all just natural
transformations
between polynomial functions
and then
given the arrangement
of all these PS inside of Q,
which is natural estimation
and giving this now
transformation here, the dynamics
in each of them,
you get the dynamics in. Q
So if I had a dynamical system
in it, so.
Q By composing natural transformations.
So this is currently the last slide.
I want to think about dynamics
a bit more.
So if you remember
a few slides ago,
I was talking about operations
in a dynamical system on P plus Q
would be one
that can switch
between P mode and Q mode.
SPIVAK: So sometimes you're out
SPIVAK: putting P stuff in and putting from it.
Sometimes you are putting Q stuff
in inputting from that.
So sorry, I'm a
little bit sick,
so my voice is not great today.
A dynamical system on p times
Q would output both simultaneously
in any state.
It's outputting both,
but it can receive from just one
or the other
a dynamical system on p tensor Q
would output both and receive from both
a dynamical system
and p composed Q would be
would do the serial protocol
where it outputs
a P and outputs a strategy
for taking any input on P
and and turning it into an output on Q.
SPIVAK: And then it would listen
for an input on P and an input a Q
so kind of just tells you, here's
what I'm going to do.
No matter what you do,
it gives you a serial protocol,
is what I'm saying.
And what about P intercom?
Q This is the in the category
polynomials functions.
There is a internal home for tensor.
SPIVAK: You may have absolutely no idea
what I'm talking about,
but it's something that comes with
the math that no one created it.
It wasn't invented.
It just is part of the structure.
Kind of like
the complex
numbers are miraculous in
the sense that you
you say you want algebraic closure
and all of a sudden
you get
you get if I have one derivative,
then I'm all derivatives
and stuff like that.
SPIVAK: So it's kind of the category
polynomial functions
is kind of miraculous.
It has tons and tons of structure
that no one asked it to have.
It just has.
But what is this structure,
this internal hum?
Well, it's the sort of thing
that runs arrangements for P and Q.
So a dynamical system on this thing
where I tensor P one, two,
three, three, four
or five comma Q and put it in brackets.
SPIVAK: This internal hall,
what it does, it's a dynamical system.
This is a polynomial,
even though it looks like
a big expression.
It's itself a polynomial.
And this polynomial has outputs
and has inputs as usual.
And so what it
dynamical system on this would do is
would be output
arrangements in the output. Okay.
Now I want you to wire two
you and you to y
or to you and you to y review.
SPIVAK: So if you were forming an institute,
you'd say, wow,
let's have
this guy report to that person
and all that sort of stuff,
and you would create some arrangement.
And then that's
what you output,
as you say, and then you listen
and you see what flows on the wires
and you see how Alice is talking to Bob
and now Bob is talking to Carla
and all that stuff.
SPIVAK: And you listen to that,
and as you listen,
you'd say, Hey, actually,
I want Bob to report to Carla
instead of Alice or whatever.
And so you would change the arrangement.
Your inner internal state
would be to listen and receive
the stuff that's flowing on the wires,
and you'd be affected by that,
and then you'd output new arrangements
for the system.
SPIVAK: And I think that's kind of
getting to this morphology thing.
Maybe maybe there are systems
that are monitoring
the sorts of transmissions
that are happening between subsystems
and then and then
now, putting new ways
that they should arrange each other.
Okay, so let me give some applications,
digital circuits and control systems
live here.
So a computer is a nested
arrangement of dynamical systems.
SPIVAK: Every transistor, the dynamical system,
and two of them make up at NAND gate and
and then you can get an or gate
by wiring together
three gates like this.
I taken my inputs
and I split them
and I feed them to NAND into the NAND
and then I put them together
and I put them into the NAND
and now I have or
and this
whole thing
is just like
NAND has two inputs and one output.
SPIVAK: This whole thing
has to input to an output,
but It's got some internal structure
and now we've got an or a gate
we could nest or gates and
and gates and NAND gates and we can get
outer circuits and multiplying
circuits and, and
alias arithmetic
units, whatever
and, and CPU's and monitors
and they're all made
just with transistors
like the memory cells are all,
are all
like flip flops are just
situated transistors.
SPIVAK: And so we can kind of
make this nested system of transistors
and get a computer.
And so the arrangement
here is all really simple.
It's never changing in time,
it's soldered in it, it's fixed
unlike us on the Zoom call.
It's dynamics are simple.
Every state is just a function
of the input only and it just use it.
SPIVAK: There's no memory
in the in the transistors
and yet because of loops in the wiring
in the arrangement,
we get
all possible
things that the computer can do.
So with enough nesting and enough
interesting arrangements,
even though the arrangements internally
are not that difficult
when you nest them,
they get really amazing in the sense
you get a computer
and that is the dynamical system
that is happening
right now, allowing for this Zoom
call to take place.
SPIVAK: I guess there's some internet stuff too
that I don't know how it's made,
but the computers made this way.
Control systems also
have complicated dynamics.
Let's say
this is a power plant or something.
But again,
I think they
basically have fixed arrangement.
So your cruise control in your car
isn't changing,
whether it's listening to the gas or the
maybe for the battery
in a in a hybrid car,
there would be a changing arrangement.
But at least the old fashioned
control systems have a fixed arrangement
of how the feedbacks
going to work to control the the speed
or whatever temperature.
Deep learning
also fits into the formalism
upon the wheel functions,
but in a different way.
Here the interfaces are all the same.
They're all outputting a real
and inputting a real
now.
And the arrangements
are all really simple.
SPIVAK: They're activated weighted sums.
Now I'm drawing this differently
than most people would.
Most people would put these
three boxes on the left of this big box
and they'd wire the three things in.
And it would seem like
this was a box taking our three
are the way I'm thinking about it,
because I want to put this
into the context of this accounting.
SPIVAK: So to a polynomial function,
it works better to think about a neuron
listening to some neurons on its left
or some predecessor thing.
So like a higher level thing,
listening to lower level things,
it makes more
sense in this formalism
to put them inside.
And then the arrangement
isn't just a fixed,
it isn't just a wiring diagram,
but it has more structure.
SPIVAK: As I said,
those wiring diagrams
were just easy cases.
Often it's more complex,
but they're still arrangements
in the sense of natural transformations,
polynomial functions.
And what this arrangement would do
is it take the output of these sub guys
and wait them, maybe
multiply this
by 3.2,
etc., add them up
and then do an activation function
and output that to the higher level,
bigger thing,
and then when it gets a loss in,
it would take the gradient
and pass the components of that
gradient to the three
or pass the
components of that loss
to the three things
and then take the gradient and change
the wiring diagram,
not the wiring
but the interaction pattern.
SPIVAK: So a change these three numbers.
So the information flowing out
is the inner box's current.
Guess about what's
going on in the world,
the current weighted sum.
It's like
these guys send out their guesses,
we add them up,
we send our guess
as the higher level manager here,
and then we get some lost function.
We distribute it to our sub units.
SPIVAK: We also use it to change the arrangement
here.
So this the changing of weights
in the training of neural network is the
is the changing arrangements
that I've been kind of pushing
this whole time, right?
The arrangement is dynamic.
The loss
not only is sent a little boxes,
but is updating the arrangement,
the collection of weights
so deep
neural networks is one of four examples
we currently have
of a certain structure that
a post-doc
working with me named Brandon
SHAPIRO and I are calling
a dynamic organizational structure
or dynamic operand.
SPIVAK: It's a fractal
like system of arrangements
that change through time,
where the arrangement decides
how information flows
through the system,
just like I've been saying.
And yet the flowing information
contains the arrangement,
just like I've been saying.
And we formalized
this using category theory
and the four examples
we have our deep learning,
which I was talking about
in the previous slide prediction markets
have been learning.
SPIVAK: So this is where Sophie Lipkin
and non-cooperative strategic games.
So we have only for example
of the structure,
but I'm guessing there are many more.
So I'm guessing, for example,
that active inference can be another one
or maybe free energy minimization
or something like that.
The point is that
these are like very fractal structures
where like be
a collection
of deep learners or gradient dissenters.
SPIVAK: If you put them together,
you get another gradient to center.
If you take a bunch of predictors
and make them into a single predictor,
you get another predictor.
So like the collection
of predictors becomes a predictor.
And the way that
the way that predictors are,
the way that wealth or trust
is distributed
between predictors
is properly nested and stuff like that
SPIVAK: didn't really go into it.
SPIVAK: But I'm interested in
whether well, I'll say that next slide.
Okay.
So wrapping up
kind of made
people think of math about number,
but it's not a math subject.
And accounting system
tracks certain things.
And what we're trying to track above
is dynamic arrangements.
The math is called polynomial functions
and it's
well known
and beloved in category theory
and it accounts
for interfaces, dynamics
and arrangements in a really nice way.
SPIVAK: And it's about building a bigger system
for little or littler parts.
It accounts for composing
circuits and control systems
and deep learning
and prediction markets.
And then you could combine these
because they're all in one formalism.
You could take your control system
and hook it up to a deep learning system
and put that in a prediction market.
And you,
all of us,
just polynomial functions
all the way down.
SPIVAK: I think it might have
been, I should
have said
might have particular value
in active inference
because it lets us talk
coherently and precisely
about these things
like changing interfaces.
I, i,
i might be wrong,
but I don't know that that's the part of
the formalism of active inference today
in terms of like
changing the arrangement
and stuff like that.
SPIVAK: But I'm interested to hear more
you guys
changing how things
communicate, change, how
the communication
pattern itself
changes as information is exchanged.
But if we wanted
to make active inference
into a
dynamic organizational structure,
for example,
you might like
dynamic organizational structure.
One person,
when they saw that, they thought, Oh,
you should really call it
multi-scale
dynamic organizational structure
in order to really clarify your
particular brand here,
but maybe not so expensive.
SPIVAK: So what would we do
if we wanted to make
free energy minimization
a dynamic organizational structure?
What we would specify all the interfaces
that we're going to be talking about
that would be used
to house energy minimization.
Like what is a free energy?
Minimize or allowed to output
and what are they allowed to input?
And you would get clear on that step one
and then you would consider
how free energy
minimizes arrange themselves, like what
an arrangement of free energy
minimization would be,
where if you arrange them in that way,
it would constitute
a larger scale of free energy,
minimize air.
SPIVAK: So that's the sort of thing
you would have to ask
to make this
into a dynamic organizational structure.
And as long as they all cohere nicely,
there was some form of check
we would do.
We would have
a dynamic organizational structure.
So to summarize,
I feel like
I've said it a million times
now, but applied category theory
is math for tracking
interlocking structures,
cohering structures.
SPIVAK: It's not about
how much of something there
is, it's about how it's arranged.
And it applies in quantum
mechanics and computer science
and math, material science
and linguistics.
But it focuses on structural questions
in each one.
It allows the content
to be something
that someone else handles later,
and it's just telling you
how you're going
to be handling that content
so that you don't kind of step
on your toes, toes as you as you use it.
SPIVAK: So I'm interested I'm interested
in the structure
of interacting dynamical systems,
like how I want to account
for be able to account for this.
I don't want to necessarily
give the account,
but I want to be able to account
for this stuff
that we're doing here together.
How we change, how we're inputting, I'm
changing by turning the speaker off
or disconnecting
and therefore not inputting the same,
or how we're outputting,
muting or camera off
and how all that affects
what happens on this call
or wherever we are and how we change
and what we learn
is how we make sense of things together.
SPIVAK: So again, I don't have specifics,
but what I'm offering
is this accounting system,
this category of polynomial functions
to account for dynamic arrangements.
And I'm hoping that it
is helpful
for thinking about active inference.
So that's it.
I'm happy to talk about stuff.
KNIGHT: That's super awesome.
David, thank you so much.
I have a million questions,
but I didn't want to interrupt
because I was really enjoying just
sharing you
because it
helps it gel
more solidly in my brain if you can.
If the interaction is like
give me all the things
and then let me like
pick apart a little pieces
and maybe that works for
hopefully the audience also.
KNIGHT: Danielle, did you
are you watching the YouTube
try to serve questions now?
Do you want to go over there?
Because I I'll interrogate him for.
SPIVAK: Okay.
SPIVAK: And this doesn't block you, does it.
This thing up here?
FRIEDMAN: No, it looks fine.
SPIVAK: Okay.
SPIVAK: I need to screen to be there.
FRIEDMAN: Luke, please begin the interrogation
and I'll be ready
with the live questions. Cool.
All right.
Okay, so
let me just go back to the beginning.
And
so in the very beginning, you said that
you feel like
after the defense kind of meshes
with category theory.
And I just am curious.
I mean, I think, like,
I kind of got a really good idea
through the course of your talk,
but maybe you could articulate the way
to maybe kind of help us understand
where that that basis is coming from.
SPIVAK: Your that's cool. Yeah.
When I when I first heard it,
it was one thing was like utility
and prediction are melded
like what I want
is I'm just expecting the world
to be a certain way
and what I want is for it
to be that way.
So if I want to
if I really if I really intend
to have something, it's
because I know that
I kind of deserve it.
SPIVAK: I can't actually.
I think people might have fantasies
where they think they can
get things
they don't deserve or something,
but it doesn't work out.
I'm not sure I feel like I'm
going into too much there, but.
But I like this idea of
melding those two things
because utility never
really made sense to me.
It's like, where do I get this
utility function from?
SPIVAK: Well, but I really
what I somehow thought was like
like what they're saying is like, my,
my knees are a certain way.
Their prediction
of like the fact that gravity
will be in a certain range
or my lungs can take in this sort of
or this way
because of a prediction
that my lineage has made
about what sort of atmosphere
I'm going to be put into
and the things I'm saying to you right
now, like utility, whatever
I'm using to decide
how good it is for me to say a
thing is my prediction of what's
what's actually wanted to hear.
SPIVAK: So I like that
SPIVAK: it was like reduce
the number of variables there,
like number of entities in the universe
or something
from utility and prediction
just to prediction.
I don't remember
like other things
exactly, but I just remember
kind of feeling like,
oh, I also like this scale free.
So free energy minimization,
for example, or, or or Bayesian predict,
you know, updating stuff
doesn't need you to be
at a particular scale.
SPIVAK: It's not about subatomic particles
or something like to scale free and
and that somehow it's a physics thing.
Like I'm really looking for a scale
free thing.
You mentioned Emergence Bleu.
I'm going to start talking to you
about something, but but
I'm not a huge fan
of the concept of emergence
because I feel like it's
usually talking,
assuming we're going to start
from a low level
and then say
and then the next level is magic.
SPIVAK: And then they start from that level,
they're like,
and then the next level is magic.
And I'm
really looking for
like the principles where,
the inductive step,
the move from end to end.
Plus one is the thing we're monitoring.
So we're never like confused.
We're like,
Well, where did this
amazing thing happen?
We're always seeing
we're monitoring that part. And
I really like that
free energy minimization
and entropy maximization
and stuff
like that
is the sort of thing that I could
imagine happening at all scales.
No matter if you're a person
or you're a cell or you're an atom.
KNIGHT: Cool. Definitely.
KNIGHT: I have to apologize
for keeping
this thing out of my background,
but I'll try to remember to mute.
But I do think that like,
yes, emergence is cool,
but also there's
this bi directional information flow.
And when we had Mike Levin
come onto the livestream,
he really talked about it
when he discusses
the computational boundary of the cells.
KNIGHT: So yes, like there are bottom up,
there are emergent properties
that happen in a collective,
but there's also top down constraints
on those emergent properties
that that
come from the quote, higher level
or maybe like larger scale.
So like if we're building things
up and down, there's constraints
that go down and information
that comes up.
And you've got to have
this bidirectional information
flow to even start to think about
drawing any kind of boundary
or creating like an interface around
the thing itself.
KNIGHT: Like that, like we,
we talked about cognitive science like
and then I don't know
if you're familiar with that paper, but
yeah, it was
cool and something else.
And so I know
like you've talked
with Mike a lot
and also with Chris Fields
and when Chris came,
he really
talked to us about contextually
and he started to get into some math
that I think is
maybe related
to some of the things
that you were talking about there.
KNIGHT: So you talked about operations
that correspond to interactions
between sets
and tests, such as about two spaces
and like channel theory.
And as these like interactions
that transform sets as info morph isms.
So like,
and I don't know
if that ends up like language
speaks to, to this or is like,
it's hard for me to tell
what is the language
of category theory and,
and what is like the application
of the category theory
to something in real life
or that's not just,
you know,
the set of X such
that X
is less equal
to like these kinds of math words.
SPIVAK: Right? Yeah.
So the two spaces stuff
is definitely category
theory and reliefs.
There's a nice way of talking about the
relationship between
two spaces upon email
functions,
although I don't
have it on the tip of my tongue
right now?
So these polynomial functions
are kind of bidirectional
because the like
if you have these arrangements
which are maps of polynomial functions,
this sort of thing, this quote unquote
higher level thing
is talking to the lower level things,
lower level
things are talking to each other
and they're also talking
to the higher level thing.
SPIVAK: So there's this kind of
SPIVAK: bidirectional thing
there and so on that level, I'd say,
yes, it does sound similar to what
Chris Fields was saying.
And then
but you also ask like,
what is the application of category?
So once you have an accounting system,
you can build a tool from it.
So if someone says, Hey,
I got this
great idea,
it's all about plus and times
and like
dollars can be added but not multiplied
and they can be multiplied by numbers
but not each other,
whatever you make this rule,
and then someone could
build a spreadsheet that
program that incorporates that rule.
SPIVAK: And maybe current spreadsheets
don't allow
you don't keep you on the rails
with respect
to not multiplying $2 figures.
But you could imagine that they
they did.
So what's the application?
The application
is it once
you have the accounting system,
the mathematical counting system,
you can build tools from it
or you can just think through it on
a whiteboard or something.
SPIVAK: But if you build tools,
let's that's a major way people use
math, calculus or whatever.
They simulate things.
You use category theory.
What you do
is you say,
I have this noodle category called poly.
And then someone says,
you know, they want to implement it.
Well, instead of thinking
about all the features
they want from an interface language,
they're like,
Oh, and let's have it
print like this
and let's have it
publish the web like that.
SPIVAK: And like,
you know, they have all these features.
What it allows you to do is not
look at any feature requests.
You could just implement
the accounting system,
you just put it in there, just the map
and you call it a day.
And then if somebody
else wants to add stuff, you do it later
and you don't use that to influence
kind of the basic code.
SPIVAK: And it allows you to break very,
very highly structured
and very compressed code that does
that does
all of the major backend
work of the thing.
And then every other feature
request is, you know,
that's kind of the gold plating
or like the thing that makes
a user interface for it. But
does that make sense
as a, as an application?
KNIGHT: Yeah.
And like perfectly segue
into my next question actually.
So so you talked about category theory
as like a potential accounting system.
And early
on, actually,
I think you even mentioned
morality in your talk,
but even before
we were talking about intelligence
and like grounding in ethics and wisdom
and I'm now like internal studying,
regenerative finance and potentially
like new ways
to develop like accounting systems
that maybe involve
like carbon credit
or some kind of moral or ethical bound.
KNIGHT: That's like a new system for like
not just plus and minus dollars,
but but maybe like a new system
for accounting that
like a ledger that that allows
for more thoughtful consideration into
sort of like the environment
and just the world at large and humanity
and our our faith
and future as a species.
And I just wonder
if you've thought about that or
and I definitely think like,
you definitely think that category,
you can maybe jump in and rescue us
or just what are your thoughts on.
SPIVAK: Yeah, so category theory,
you have to do the work of deciding
what your accounting system is concerns.
It's like it helps you decide what
what things
since it is talked about all of math
it can be written a category theory
at this point
or at least all that I can think of
it's got
all of
math is the stuff that people have used
so far to think about the world.
SPIVAK: And so it's somehow getting all of that
into a system.
So it's likely that whatever
we're thinking about now,
if this were generated, finance, etc.,
if you know,
there would be some good way
of putting it into category theory.
But that's still has to be done.
It won't rescue you, except
it'll be there as like,
yeah, I think I could.
SPIVAK: If I had an expert to work with,
I could do it.
But then in terms of the question itself
for generative finance and
and that's and morality
and stuff like that, well,
I mean,
I don't know
if this is the sort of thing
that comes to mind,
but one thing I think in our society
that might be pretty bad
and is in ourselves also,
or at least
maybe it's good, but it's good in a way
I don't understand yet.
SPIVAK: And that is
that in these big arrangements, there's
little things whose job it is to hide
the intentions of the things inside.
And so,
like, I think I'm not sure
I'm going to name this person
and it's almost a trigger, but
Jeffrey Epstein,
I think like, what was he good at?
I kind of think I know
he was known
for like
making these financial
derivative instruments that like
hid the, the,
the subprime mortgage stuff.
SPIVAK: And I feel like his whole island
and all this stuff he was doing, like
he just knew
all the secrets and his
and I could imagine
backing away from him.
But like also like the meat industry,
there is secrets
about how meat is produced.
And when you go to the supermarket,
their job is to make sure you don't
think about that stuff.
SPIVAK: And so
when you form these big arrangements
or the financial system
like there's
a lot of what goes on
in the financial system
that's hiding the
almost slavery
that takes place in various places.
So and in myself,
maybe the greed, I think all
this is really coming from
the need to survive
at all costs
or something like that,
that it seems like our cells in our body
SPIVAK: don't have. But we somehow have gotten.
I'm not sure about that.
So anyway, one thing that comes to
mind is like,
what's up with hiding intentions?
And do is there any place for that?
KNIGHT: Well, also, just like from
from a very biological perspective,
I do think that
we have little things inside of us
because not function.
It is to hide things.
But I definitely don't have access
to that.
The all of the knowledge
of every single cell in my body
or every even orgasm.
So, so I mean, like
survive at all costs.
KNIGHT: Like,
KNIGHT: yes, I could be like monogamous
with going a little cancer
tumor somewhere that's not known to me.
And like we have mechanisms
that mask
pain and even mask
like proprioception or so.
So there's a lot of things going
on, like there's a lot of hiding
even in file in the biological system
that happens between skills
which totally leads
into my next question so perfectly,
which is about compression
and elaboration.
KNIGHT: And so like what is hidden
or what is compressed, right?
And what is the relationship
or function or
utility of category theory
in elaborating compression
and elaboration,
like if I get the compressed version
of like
what the larger box container
is, what's happening
with the larger box?
Can I elucidate the structure
and what's happening
in the smaller boxes
or the even the arrangement
of the smaller boxes in the within,
the larger container,
the larger scale, say
and just so,
so how much how good is this math?
KNIGHT: Is it going to how
how is it going to help me understand
compression and elaboration
across scales?
SPIVAK: Yeah, cool.
I first
want to say that
I think of category theory
as humanity's
best thought compression language.
I didn't.
Yeah.
So for example, the category of
polynomial functions is
the whole
subcategory function
from set to set span
by products of represented this.
And I told you the entire definition
and I don't expect you to understand it,
and I wouldn't even expect of category
theorists to understand it.
SPIVAK: But I would write that expression
that I just said
on the board and would be,
I don't know, 20 words or 30 words.
And then
that would be sitting there at the top.
And then I would go through like,
what do I mean by category?
What do I mean by set?
What I mean by filter?
What do I mean by stand by?
SPIVAK: What do I mean by co-product
and what do I mean by represent?
And I would go through
those words
and I would explain
whichever ones of those
who didn't understand,
and then I would
explain those in a compressed way.
And then you'd say, Yeah, I get that.
Or No, I don't get that.
And we could unpack thing.
So the category theory itself
before we get to your question
about the interfaces and arrangements
is, is this amazing
thought compression language
where all the stuff in this talk,
all the math behind it
and the stuff is all
it is an all in elaboration of of this
very very compressed
few words
because we really made this language
SPIVAK: for compressing big thoughts.
Then there if I remember,
I hope I'm not missing
the main part of the question.
But you were also talking about the
arrangements themselves
as compression and
and yeah,
like an outer circuit is a compression
of a bunch of and or logic circuits
that are themselves
a compression of NAND gateway
to themselves,
transistors arranged in a certain way,
a certain way, certain way.
SPIVAK: And the NAND gate,
if you think about it,
why did you arrange
those two transistors that way?
Because you knew
that it would always act this way.
You can kind of like
everyone's demanding
all the time, but
or is a pretty good thing to think about
and and is a
pretty good thing to think about
and plus is pretty good.
SPIVAK: And so these compressions,
out of all the possible
ways of arranging transistors
into the number of transistors
in the outer
circuit that can add to
three digit numbers
or something like that,
that might I don't know.
Let's just pretend that took
ten that took a thousand transistors.
If I out of all the ways of arranging
a thousand transistors,
there's like a few
that you would actually like
that where you're like
instead of two numbers
and getting like some random thing,
you get the actual sum.
SPIVAK: And so we compress into for some reason
some compressions are useful
because we can predict them.
And like I can kind of predict
your behavior
based on what
I'm seeing out on your face
and, and what you need to know from me
or what I can do to help and vice versa.
And Like
that ability to compress all this stuff
into just something
you output on
the interface is is really important
in the same is happening in the organ
in the in the outer circuit and stuff.
SPIVAK: So you kind of create things
that have a well-defined usefulness,
even though I have
no idea what that means.
And and I don't know,
does that answer the question
or did I miss a major part of it?
KNIGHT: So let me just repeat a part of this.
So if I am a compression, say like,
let me just do something really simple.
I'm the number six
and I'm a compression of,
you know, three numbers.
And it can be.
So can I, can I?
I guess what I compress
is the set of the possible numbers
that make up six, like the three.
KNIGHT: That's what I compress. Right.
So that's what translates
to the compression.
So you can never really go
from the compression
number six, figure out
which of those three numbers were right.
SPIVAK: Right, right.
But you can what you do know
is the remaining
thing that sickness gives you
there's lots of things that use six
and they're all happy to know about six
and same with or like
I don't know how you made your
you could have made it
with 43,000 transistors
and wasted a bunch of them.
But the point is
I don't need to know all that stuff.
SPIVAK: All I need to know
is that this thing is going to take
2 billion and produce a boolean
in a certain way.
And so the compression,
this outer interface is saying,
I don't care
about all your private methods.
Just tell me like,
what can I expect from you?
And I think part of like,
you know, in our society
we have identities.
SPIVAK: I'm guessing that identity,
which is such a major thing
today, is like this compression
of like what's expected from the person.
And
we, we are working out like
how those identities really do help us
expect things from each other.
KNIGHT: So just on a topic of identity
and like to follow up and maybe continue
this train of thought a little bit.
So like I am Bleu, I am a human.
Like I'm a human that's alive,
that's here.
Talking under the compression
of mass stream number 4.1,
which all of this conversation
will eventually confess to.
Active Institute Mastering 4.1.
KNIGHT: But, but like the fact that I am
Bleu and I am human, like
I am one among the set of many things
that is all human.
And like we describe the set,
like living human in a certain way.
Like I have a certain number of cells,
but many of the cells are not human
like so, so more so at some times your
digestive cycle than others.
KNIGHT: The more so sometimes are not human
then actually are human.
And so it's these set of like things,
how many human cells, how many
different E coli, so many
different types of bacteria
and microorganisms.
And like
all of these things
compressed to the set of like
living human,
I would like to be able to unravel
like, well,
it is like go from living human or like
you can just find
the limits of like, okay,
so now like too many E
coli was like some decomposing human
that's not alive.
KNIGHT: So like, I would like to be able
to really push the boundaries of what
or even find
the boundary of,
of what makes the set of cells
that is a living human versus
like when do you
it's like the phase transition,
like the critical point.
At what critical point
are so many of these microorganisms
alive that I become
not a living human anymore?
SPIVAK: Yeah. Yeah.
So in the same way
a an end gate is not made out of
and gates
it's made out of smaller
things or, you know, a logic. Right.
So we don't really expect
the high level thing
to be made out of little things.
But the reason
I think you're saying that there are
these things called human cells
is because we share this DNA and the DNA
that you're tracking when you say there,
hey, do you call, I is not me.
SPIVAK: And the bacterial gut,
gut bacteria stuff is not me
because it doesn't have our
DNA, but it is
you in the sense that it helps
you as a pattern exist.
And so if I was putting
an interface around you,
I definitely wouldn't
personally want to like
only use your DNA cells
and call those of you
because I would be
you wouldn't be a very good you.
SPIVAK: But yeah.
So what can happen
is like these E coli
or these cancers
or whatever inside of you,
let's say you're this gigantic of stuff,
that what can happen
is that they can start to say things
that start to mess with that arrangement
and start to change the arrangement.
And so, remember,
the arrangement is changing on
what's flowing through the wires.
SPIVAK: So your E coli things in there
might be saying some stuff
or spreading some stuff
that's changing the arrangement.
And now this cell is no longer
talking about cell when it should have.
And now that it's no longer
talking to that cell
because the arrangement has changed
now it is now that other cell
is not receiving what it usually does.
SPIVAK: So it starts to say different things.
And slowly this
this changes the arrangement
so much that you're no longer
a coherent whole.
And the things
that we can expect from you
your identity has changed to one
that's like not as interesting.
KNIGHT: Definitely.
KNIGHT: And so can you see that in the
with the math, like
where this maybe
phase transition
takes place
or like at what level of rearrangement,
like maybe it's 20% rearrangement
or like 20% coherent arrangement or
measures like the
information in the circuitry
transferring from one to
like from one piece to another such that
like when the information flow
is so disrupted,
then it ceases to be
a functional arrangement.
SPIVAK: Yeah, I,
I think that problem is as hard
is like being able
to look at a spreadsheet
and seeing if there's corruption
like people can do it.
But it's a judgment.
It's like someone decides, like, no,
that's not, that's not real
or yeah, it's like,
I know it when I see it kind of thing.
So there might be rules of thumb
you could create
in this accounting system like
but I doubt
I don't feel comfortable like the,
the definition of the faith transition
and I wouldn't expect it to be
any more than
a judgment, but yeah.
KNIGHT: Well, thank you
and thanks for letting me kind of ramble
on a little bit there.
So on the sidebar, we're here
totally changing the subject.
If you were a Roman,
like if you were ancient
Roman using
ancient Roman numerals,
would Hindi Arabic numerals
still be empirically better
or does that depend on context?
SPIVAK: I think they would.
I actually know that it might not be
in the current culture,
but I think
I think it is just empirically better.
Like in a sense,
like is a better baseball player better?
Well, they're better at baseball.
Like, I'm not saying that's better.
Like maybe you just love these things
and it makes you feel really good
to see cases and stuff.
SPIVAK: And then for you,
like it's great like you use this thing,
but if you want to be a math person
that multiplies things
like you
apparently in Rome,
like if they were,
they knew about square
root of two back then.
They figured out like
1.41 for apparently. I don't know.
I don't know if that's true.
But they were
Pythagoras was like back then like
can you imagine
taking square root
if this is what you're using, it's just
you can barely multiply like
how could you take it to a power and do
could we do quantum mechanics today
if we were having to do this,
could we do
could we do even compound with this
like I would never, ever want like
so it just wins.
Like it just
it's empirically better
because those who decide to move to
this system will outcompete this.
And in life
there is some sort of competition
and
so I do think that
it's empirically better,
but I'm happy to hear if you disagree.
KNIGHT: I mean, I do think like,
you know,
survival of the fittest, right?
So so
clearly like the Hindi
Arabic numerals have have one.
But but also
I think
that if I had never seen a Hindi Arabic
numeral before
and was trying to multiply that like
I would first
because it's like
just one
I'm familiar with, it's
part of my model
is to use these Roman numerals.
KNIGHT: If I were in ancient Rome
and I would be like,
What is this one for? You know?
And so it's just whatever,
I guess that you're,
you're familiar with.
It's but but it's it's
neat to hear your perspective also.
SPIVAK: I mean, like if you were a moth
and it was turning, you know, this
everything was turning brown
because of new smoke.
You might be familiar
with being a white moth,
but like
any moth that tends to being a brown
moth would win.
I don't know.
Yeah, there's familiarity
and that is a thing
because we need that.
We need homeostasis and stuff.
SPIVAK: But there's I don't know.
Yeah, I think that
if someone was a more capable person
in terms of being able to change,
they would,
they would appreciate that faculty
themselves.
Like they'd be like, I'm glad I tried
to change.
Yeah.
KNIGHT: Well, and so now I have a series
of questions about
the interface
and the dynamics and interactions.
I don't know
if you want to
skip forward to the slides.
So these are these like terms
like you said,
you have some key terms, interface
dynamics, interaction, and I'm tracking
these terms.
Are they
part of
like the formalism of category theory?
KNIGHT: Is this something that like
everyone is a category they're studying,
they're not. Okay.
So that was my my question was,
you know, because the way that you
discussed these interfaces, positions
versus states arrangements and closures
really spoke to active inference so much
like I really get why you're like,
oh yeah, that seems to like kind of mesh
with my current ideas.
KNIGHT: Like,
so like we have the interface
which we talk about like
a marcos blanket,
like a separation of boundary
and in the markup, like
I like the sense states
and the actual states.
So like in the interface
it is like you would call it positions
and forces.
Like that's where I act on the world
and the world acts back on me.
KNIGHT: Like in the Marcos boundary.
And so similarly like talk
about like the dynamics of the system
as being hidden
only like internal to the system.
And we have like hidden states
like our internal states.
And then yeah, the interaction is like
what I would refer to as like
a state update, like, like
so there's like, you know, we interact
and then I might change or I might,
it might just influence my
future trajectory.
KNIGHT: So I just wanted to
highlight that the great degree
of similarity
between what you talked about
and like what we talk
about very regularly and actually
inference is great.
SPIVAK: So what I did was I took,
I started noticing
polynomial functions, wanted to do
what I was trying to do
and then
I took the feeling of using them.
Like when I
the intuition I get by asking myself
what a map
of polynomial functions
is or whatever,
and came up with these words
as the things that most
like most intuitive
English words
that tracked
how the math was was changing
or how the math
developed as I
made a story about these things.
SPIVAK: So these are really just the words
that I found to most.
Give me intuition for tracking
what the math was
was doing automatically.
It looks like Daniel
has his hand raised.
FRIEDMAN: I think you just great
questions Bleu and David
thanks for the very
powerful and creative talk.
I think
on this topic of the active inference
ontology mapping,
I think that was really quite
well stated,
which is
this idea of an input output system
or an interface and things that are on
one side of the interface
are shielded
from that
on the other side of the interface.
FRIEDMAN: Otherwise quite literally
it would be a different thing
is a really powerful idea
and it comes up in computer science
with APIs,
it comes up in graphs and topology,
and we can even think about things
like the arithmetic operations,
like of operations
or nested parentheses.
It's like, well,
what happens in the parentheses?
It stays in the parentheses
until it's compressed
and then it goes into some other area.
FRIEDMAN: And then also even how you described
searching for intuitive words
and I'm sure actively
inferring with many learners for terms
have a natural interpretation
or a conversational interpretation
and also point towards more technical
usage, which I think in active inference
we see a lot about system delineation
and partitioning from the environment
like such as the ones that brought up
nested systems and interacting systems.
FRIEDMAN: And also
regarding some numerical quantities
like surprise attention and so on.
Although also we have recently seen
some symbolic active
inference implementations
from JF cluster
that are engaging in this action
perception loop
without sending statistical
or numerical messages,
but rather
communicating about logic values.
So I just wanted to note that and
if you have any thoughts
otherwise, I'll read a question
from the chat. Um, yeah.
A quick
thought is like somehow
when I
we take language, for example, math,
and we translate it into motion.
So like if you say please pass the salt,
then like 10 to 15
atoms will move through space.
You know,
you say this word in language
and in ten to the 15 atoms
move through space
and like some salt crystals land on your
on your food or whatever.
SPIVAK: And so
by having the math
into intuitive ideas
in our in our minds,
we can then take the mathematical ideas
and translate them
into the movement of atoms.
So like me being able to talk or,
or whatever
and like
it's really important
that we have intuitive ways
of thinking about these things
because otherwise
they won't translate down
into the movement of atoms
that actually the action
that we see in the world, that actually
accomplishes anything.
So I'm
SPIVAK: I'm worried about all the mathematicians
that are doing math
that they don't have any sense at all
about how it could ever be used.
And this is kind of the point of Tobias
Institute is like
you can I don't mind if you do it
like okay, you can do whatever you want.
But like
I don't see a point in doing math
if you no idea how that would ever
be useful to anyone
even in a thousand years.
SPIVAK: And so I'm,
I don't know so yeah to connect
the point is like to
to connect
with the audience here
have this possibly
be useful to anyone for real.
I need to find the words
that take the math
and translate it into intuitive concepts
so that they can come back
to the math that they
want to or whatever.
FRIEDMAN: Yeah, Lou, anything to add
on it?
KNIGHT: Go ahead and read the chat questions.
Great.
SPIVAK: All right.
FRIEDMAN: So this will
pull us
back, generalize a little bit,
and then I'm
sure we could
talk more
active inference or institute talk.
So Ali wrote
it is said that category theory is,
the most abstract
area of mathematics out there, perhaps
we can even call it
a kind of meta mathematics.
Daniel Dennett
claims in intuition
and other tools for thinking
that we can theoretically
go meta on every level of abstraction.
FRIEDMAN: So is it possible to conceive a level
of abstraction
even more meta
than category theory in mathematics?
SPIVAK: Yeah, great question.
So
there is a category of all categories.
There is.
The thing is that
when you have a category
of all categories,
first of all, it's like
really big and second of all,
it has an
even higher level structure
that than each category does.
So it's called a two
category of all categories.
And then there's a three category
about two categories.
SPIVAK: And but there is amazingly
a thing called infinity categories
that finishes this thing
where there is an infinity category
of all infinity categories.
And I think
I think that that the abstract
like is very hard
to think about this thing,
but it is still an active area
of, of research
to create like a nice infinity category.
But the but yeah, people
keep getting stuck on, hey,
I've got this category,
I've got all these categories
and I want something more abstract
and then I need a two category
and I'm done.
SPIVAK: I got the
two category of all categories,
but then eventually someone
the next one. And so
so yeah, this is
this is a great question.
It is an active area of research
right now. Okay.
Interesting.
I'll ask one
active inference
related question that connects
also to enclosures and nesting.
So we've in the generative models
that we see in active inference,
they're Bayesian graphs
and they're describing control
systems and action perception loops
and so on.
We've seen nested models be used
in at least two different ways.
One is to describe systems
who are physically nested
within one another, such as an organism,
and then the organs,
the cells, the organelles
and those interfaces and.
FRIEDMAN: What that nesting or enclosing
can be interpreted
as has a natural spatial interpretation.
However, there have also been
nested models
of cognitive modeling flavors,
and in those cases it's never been clear
whether the nesting or enclosing
that's happening
is reflecting spatial boundaries
in some cognitive space.
If one chooses that
direction of interpretation
or in fact what that nesting entails,
and then importantly why it would have
a structural ice amorphous m
with the nesting of the matryoshka
and just things
that are physically
nested inside of each other.
FRIEDMAN: So what does nesting and enclosure
mean here,
and is it
referring to spatial boundaries?
Other conceptual boundaries.
SPIVAK: Yeah.
Great. So
this so
like same with airplanes or something.
We have the physical airplane,
but then
different parts of the airplane
are really talking to each other.
That may not be like
the radio
of the control tower
and the radio of the airplane
are in some sense
more closely connected than.
The radio of the airplane
and the engine of the airplane,
the the radio,
the airplane
and the radio
and the pilot are strongly connected.
SPIVAK: And so, yeah,
there's always this logical,
what I would call physical arrangement
and logical arrangement,
and those might be different.
But what are from this point of view
or one thing you could do is just
so if you if you look at,
I don't know, this x one,
two and X two, one,
you might imagine that there's
a logical way of arranging things
where these really seem like
they're quite close. And so
I probably
should have shown this,
but that picture
is the same as this one.
I've just undone the nesting.
Let's see if I can kind of show that.
So yeah, let's see. This is.
Oh, no, it's not.
Oh, darn it.
I didn't take the same one.
It's confusing.
Okay, well,
I think I added an extra
loop on this thing or something.
SPIVAK: Anyway, my point is,
we can undo this nesting and have it be
have this one
be closer to this one
in some other nesting.
So you could use
this organizational system
called an operator
to handle the fact
that you might want to
nest things
differently for different purposes.
This picture here is supposed to be
either physical arrangement
or logical arrangement.
SPIVAK: It doesn't matter.
And it's really just
about who's talking to who.
That's the most important thing.
The thing is that in your liver
or in your brain, in your cell,
maybe
the latency of communication
is much greater
than across the boundaries.
Sorry for the
voice issue.
FRIEDMAN: Well, very interesting.
And in neuroscience
speaks to the distinctions
of structural, functional
and affective connectivity, which
if only it was dominoes
hitting each other
and they were all identical.
But even in that case,
I don't think they would be identical.
So we're dealing with something
and that's a great example
where the informational
and the causal connectivity,
after all the Bayesian
causal graph architecture
is pointing towards
something that is presenting itself
as cause
with a technical specific definition,
although a natural word.
FRIEDMAN: And so it is interesting
when the causal architecture
may not reflect
the physical architecture
and vice versa. Right.
And that's the opera
and the notion of opera,
which I never said during the talk. But
this nesting thing is
is designed to allow you to rearrange
how you want to consider
inside and outside,
or whether you want to
consider physical or logical
to allow you to do that
zooming on your own time
or you're in your own way
without affecting
what the thing
is going to do as a whole.
FRIEDMAN: Thank you, Bleu.
KNIGHT: So just to add on to the possible
layers of nesting,
there's also the layer
of temporal nesting, right?
So things happen at a very fast pace
that we don't observe,
like delay the slip
flickering as long
as it's greater than 60 hertz.
I don't see it flickering,
but I know flickering.
As long as it's
not in my perceptible range,
then it doesn't really matter to me. So.
KNIGHT: So there's
and just
similarly,
I don't think biological evolution
maybe cares
all that much about mastering 4.1,
but cares about like how many children
we each have
and all these other things, right?
So that, that the, the relevance,
the salience
and across temporal scales is also
something to think about.
And we talked about
like the changing interface,
I think you mentioned that
and with with the question of like
I don't know
if active inference
does this changing interface also
it does in the mark of which
we just actually learned
about and talked about
when we were talking
about quantum systems with Chris
and Mike and John.
KNIGHT: So that was
KNIGHT: I think livestream number 40.
FRIEDMAN: Also on on that technical
note,
I would suggest
that the plain essence
of the blanket
definition does not entail
any sort of dynamical rearrangement.
However, recent work by Dalton s
and others
has pointed
towards a definition of a blanket index
which reflects a weekly mixing dynamical
interface zone
that is on a 0 to 1 continuum
and that may point towards
the kind of rearrange of all interfaces,
although not with the kind of
category theoretic nature.
FRIEDMAN: As far as I know.
But again,
this is like a very interesting area
and I can see many applications
in systems
including online teams and organization.
And so I really like that.
You used what was that Hans
and I
for making some of these connections
clear, cool.
KNIGHT: And just just one last connection.
You had mentioned your applied
to apply the tools
that you're facing right now
and you mentioned prediction markets.
And I do think that.
Well well,
first of all, you talked about like
before you talked about that
you talked about the free energy
minimizes
sort of
each little component in the system
is the free energy minimizing
and how like it
within the FP
it can
scale to form like a container
free energy
for energy minimize it
so yes and that will stay a free energy.
KNIGHT: The free energy minimize
as long as it decreases
the free energy of all of the components
in the container
for it to stay in container. Right.
So that's that speaks self-assembly
and perhaps of the genesis.
And then in these
so again,
consider how free energy minimizes
the range themselves. There we go.
And how
constitute a larger scale
free energy minimize
or if it lowers the free energy?
KNIGHT: And then just in terms of application
prediction markets,
I think is a really good way to
maybe align
category theory with the FCP.
And I think some of that has been done.
I want to say like the multi arm band it
problem is maybe like
like a rudimentary example of that
and I don't remember
which livestream that was.
KNIGHT: It was a long time ago,
but we did have a paper
dealing with the multi band
the problem and using that to solve it.
And that might be
a way to start to learn like.
FRIEDMAN: On the
just on the prediction market area.
And then, David, really curious to hear
what you think.
I see a lot of parallels with what
you described about transistors.
Again,
you said a thousand pieces components
in this transistor.
The space of the a thousand pick
and connections might be vast.
And so that's where
like selective processes
and abduct of logic
come into play with this
two stroke engine of like diversifying
and exploring the space and pruning down
based upon function.
FRIEDMAN: And so we could imagine
prediction markets
where the next mate level
the the the colony participants
is making great predictions,
but then they're being compiled
in a way that's actually inadequate.
We could also imagine the other extreme
where no nest mate knows
how much food the colony has or what
the weather is outside, etc.
But it's natural actions
still participate
in a colony or in a market
that makes adaptive decisions.
FRIEDMAN: So in that structuring
of multi-scale sense, making
the composability
and the ability to create systems
that are valid across scales
and don't enforce any kind of
implausible constraints,
it becomes essential because
people point
sometimes to wisdom of crowds
and all these other related areas,
and there's probably some areas
and some ways of doing it
that are just incredibly effective.
FRIEDMAN: And I'm sure we can think of
crowds and ways of doing it
and questions
where it is just not that way.
SPIVAK: Yeah.
SPIVAK: So in this in this work of unknown
dynamic organizational structures,
there is a kind of fractal
like nature to it where the same thing,
like there's one formula
for the whole thing.
And so in order to be
one of these things
like in this technical sense that we
wrote up,
it can have all sorts of crazy stuff
at one level that doesn't
exist at no level like we.
SPIVAK: This is not supposed to be
an indictment of it.
But we tried to make a more socialist
example of a trick prediction market
where the wealth of, the
the updated wealth
would be more evenly distributed.
And it wasn't like it didn't
it didn't have fractal
like property where
what would happening
at the high level
with coherence
with what was happening to low level
and so it could have been
because we weren't
we were creative enough or whatever.
SPIVAK: But my main point is that there are
there are rules to this system
that say when it's
going to kind of
align across the entire structure.
And when it does,
then you get a very short description
that that happens at all scales.
And so
what what this kind of tracking system
allows is to say,
I mean, you don't have to trust
that dynamic organizational structures
are a good system.
SPIVAK: But if you were like, well, we need some
something to guide us here,
then you could use it to say,
Well, this way of assembling predictions
to make our little prediction
just doesn't work
as one of these dynamic
organizational structures.
And therefore,
we're going to deny it
as the way we're going to do stuff
because they're just not going to work
when we do multi-scale things.
SPIVAK: These four examples
do so in heavy learning.
For example, what we
what we mean by
that is
spike time
dependent plasticity
where like what happens if, if I hear
you say the same kind of balance
as, as me, but you said it like 1/2 ago,
whereas I'm saying it
now, then,
then I want to wire to
you more strongly.
SPIVAK: So this kind of, like just
this kind of time horizon where
I'm listening for your
your agreement with me
and if you did before me
that I want to wire to you more
that itself.
There is a way putting this together
that has this kind of fractal
like structure,
but there's tons of ways of doing it
that don't.
SPIVAK: And so that that's kind of
what's going on here.
FRIEDMAN: In in what you
just said with
a short description across scales.
I see it reflected in that definition.
You wrote up on the chalkboard
that could be uncompressed
and in Pass the salt
or pass the salt, please.
And then in the organizational setting,
that kind of multi-scale decision
making and ability to address
a kind of integrated
stack of scales
such that
there is a compression
like I am running,
which is describing
a coherent set of actions
ranging all the way down
to the, to the cellular and molecular
that can be semantically compressed
in a verbal or linguistic community
in a certain way.
FRIEDMAN: And there's other people
who you say, I'm running
and they're going to look at you like,
What language are you speaking?
So it still is contextual, yet
we can have these
multi-scale or descriptions.
And then
I have a note from Kevin in the chat
in case it hasn't been noted,
it might be worth mentioning to David
that Markov blankets
in active inference
are just a kind of Bayesian network
directed acyclic graphs
with probabilities
assigned to the vertices
for all those
who will be following this trail
and working to build this relationship,
hopefully between category
theory and active inference.
FRIEDMAN: Thank you, Kevin.
SPIVAK: Cool.
Thanks.
KNIGHT: So very cool.
I think we're coming up on time.
David,
do you want to tell us
maybe a little bit about
or if we have any questions first
that we would happy to
maybe attempt to elaborate?
Or also,
if you want to tell us
a little bit
about this institute
and what your goal and function are,
how you came to, you know, self-assemble
in that form. That would be great.
Sure.
Yeah.
Basically, in in academia, there is no
I my co-founder
Brendan and I wrote a textbook.
There is no interest in
writing in academia.
I especially like to help people
learn a new subject.
There's no reward for it.
There's no reward in the math
for making tools out of the math
or trying to help people
either learn it or use it.
And so
basically I'd been at MIT
for eight years
and then my department said,
We now have a new policy
that you can only be here five years
if you don't have tenure.
And I didn't have tenure.
I was a research scientist.
And so he gave me a two
and a half years to two go.
And so
I was like, Well, okay,
that makes sense because academia
doesn't care about, you know,
about the
stuff that I'm really trying to do.
And so Brendan and I made institute
because we actually want
the stuff we're doing to help the world
make more sense of things like we are
this gigantic,
you know, we've,
we've,
we're a network of people
that the world that has to steer
it has to decide is
climate change really?
You know, is is Obama a muslim?
We don't know these answers.
Apparently, we don't
we can't figure these things out.
And that just
I think it's
because we don't have the communication
to to to to do that.
And so I just want like
I think there's just it's not because
I think there is this
greed thing in everyone
or this need to survive or whatever
it is.
It's hiding of information
that is probably causing problems.
And I don't really understand it.
And you're right, like
we don't need
everything out in the open.
But mostly I think what's really causing
problems is just lack of communication.
It's like my greed.
If I understood
how it was affecting you,
maybe I wouldn't
need to do this particular one.
And like,
if you understood
how the scientists
came to the idea of climate change
and you could track
track that to the level you want it to,
you could
actually, you
know, understand these things.
Then maybe you wouldn't question it.
It's just that, like,
you haven't done the experiment
for yourself
and you're not trusting
that it's done in the right way.
And so I was hoping at least that
the more
we can help people
communicate and understand each other
and have high fidelity accounting system
so we can be accountable,
the more we can solve problems together
and like things
that wasn't
being rewarded in academia itself,
we, we needed to go outside and position
between academia
and industry and society.
So that's how we decided to form,
to post.
That.
That notion
of accountable communication
is really powerful
because we see cases
where communications
are accounted
for, metadata,
logging and peer review
and where are we accountable socially?
Where is it
a digital accountability
and the accounting schemes are askew
and so people are looking at their shred
of the spreadsheet
and uncertain on how those numbers
were derived,
whether It's the whole picture.
Or do you have all the sheets
in that file, like
with a partial picture?
And yet the space of
communication strategies just like that
thousand part transistor board was vast.
Well,
there's more than a thousand people.
And so the space of communication
simply edges, let alone quality and tone
and content is so vast that again, it
emphasizes the need for a vocabulary
and a grammar
and a
syntax of composable,
dynamic organizational structures.
So we can even begin to be working
not just in this one
very local
potentially reason in organizational
space.
Yeah, I totally agree.
I mean, in computers, in the Internet,
we have very composable things
that you can really make math out of
and at every scale in some sense
there is like
the same sort of thing happening.
And this allows computer scientists
to talk to each other and guy working.
So we're working on
like internet protocols
and some transistors.
On some level
they can kind of talk,
but like an urban planning person
and a, you know, a biologist, geneticist
and a mathematician and like,
I don't know, whatever.
It's like these people across society,
they have their like talking
and wingding said each other
like they're just like,
you know,
mailbox, envelope, ampersand
and like they don't understand
what each other is talking about.
And that we're never going to
if we can't cohere.
Like there's
this all these little languages
that are not coherent together.
And in category theory,
there's tons of languages,
a language of topology,
there's a language of algebra,
the language of logic and logic.
You know,
there's number theory,
there's tons and tons of languages
and each one needs to be an isolated
like needs to have its own space
so it can develop notation for itself,
so it can develop techniques for itself
and not have to ask
anybody else's permission and.
What category theory?
And same
with like urban planning and genetics
like they don't.
And the geneticist
doesn't want to say like,
oh, sorry,
I used
the word, you know, structure
and I know
already using the word structure.
So we'll call it something else
like they don't want to like
have to do that.
And yet in category theory,
what it allows you to do
in math is take topology
and make an analogy
with number theory or with algebra
and actually send information
that can lands intact
because the function tells you
what you're expecting to keep
and what you're expected
to lose across this connection
and anything you expect
and keep, it keeps.
And so what we're hoping for
is that by creating
like finding
languages that that you can use
across lots of disciplines,
from epidemiology to
chemistry or whatever,
we can
create single like
languages and then connect them
to other languages,
database languages and physics languages
and stuff like that,
and allow them to each evolve
and create their own independent
notation and techniques
and yet be able to have that interface,
that compress thing
sends something across the boundary
to somebody else
and have it arrive intact
in a trustworthy and accountable way.
Awesome.
Well, David,
thanks for hanging out with us
and talking to us about Category three
and maybe come back and talk to us
some more about it
and maybe we can align deeper on
on the relationship
between the type of things
that you're discussing
and to activate it. That's great.
That's great.
Yeah.
Thanks a lot for the invitation
to to be with you guys today.
Okay, thanks.
Thank you, David.
Good bye. Bye.